on saturday three army rangers from cfb
borden in southern ontario flew to
bearskin lake for the day to assess what
resources a full military deployment
would need the community in bearskin
lake had asked for as many as 40
military personnel ready to stay for up
to 14 days they would have to
come up with their own tents
that's how bad it is in this situation
in my community it has been a week since
the chief asked for military help after
declaring a state of emergency in late
december i'm surprised i'm surprised
that has taken this
long and so slow the progress that's
been taken so far
but finally on sunday afternoon the
federal government said it would send
help the government said four army
rangers are going in now and an
unspecified number later but the
community says they've been told three
now and three later for a total of six
in any event a community spokesperson
said they are disappointed with the
response and still feel overwhelmed and
unsupported the 40 soldiers that the
community had asked for are needed to
spell off exhausted volunteers and
exhausted community leaders like the
chief who tested positive himself for
coven 19 on saturday i'm okay at the
moment
but i wasn't feeling too too good this
morning but i think i'm starting to feel
okay now the chief got sick even though
he has had his booster in fact 80
percent in the community are fully
vaccinated because of that there had
been no serious illness at least so far
that required medical evacuations still
with all but 20 or 30 of the community's
400 residents locked in self-isolation
there is an urgent need for people who
can supply wood food and medicine
and to provide relief for the
community's nurses there are less than
half a dozen looking after 200 sick
people i have
elderly parents at home that they've
been tested positive and there's nobody
to look after them
but i'm grateful the nurses go and check
upon them once
a day bearskin lake though just might be
the first of several remote northern
communities that are going to ask for
the military's help already we're
hearing from some northern manitoba
first nations communities that say
they'll be overwhelmed unless the
canadian forces pitches in